controversial then and now 2010 and the
cross bench Pier baroness Cox welcomes
the far-right Dutch politician Gert
vilders to the UK
no documents obtained by the anti-racism
campaign group hope not hate and shared
with Sky News raise questions about how
baroness Cox has been funding more
recent parliamentary work
money from a U.S organization fieldstead
and Company was sent to a firm now
called equal and free limited of which
baroness Cox is a director from here
funding was used to pay for a
parliamentary researcher to help with
the peers private members Bill focused
on Islamic marriage
this is the Los Angeles organization the
money originated from run by two
Evangelical philanthropists fieldstead
and company has links to Orthodox
Christian groups and political causes
that campaign against same-sex marriage
there's no suggestion of any wrongdoing
by The Firm but those who want Lord's
reform say change is needed so we know
that there's 800 Lords appointed by the
Prime Minister and they are encouraged
to have outside interests and outside
expertise but of course this creates a
real gray area when it comes to lobbying
who's funding these interests where's
the money coming from baroness Cox
updated her register of interests who
include her company and the support it
provides for her work after she was
approached by Sky News saying the
Omission was an oversight but the rules
here mean she doesn't have to declare
where the money came from initially or
how much has been received
the leaked documents also include
minutes of meetings held for many years
here on the Parliamentary estate under
the name of the new issues group that
have been attended by prominent and
controversial critics of Islam Islam is
not a religion of Peace minutes from
2013 state the anti-islam activist Emery
Waters was asked to help write a Lord's
question for baroness Cox while in 2016
the peer took the ukip politician and
Tommy Robinson supporter Alan Craig to a
meeting with the government Minister
that same year a memo written by a group
member and circulated to attendees
stated that Islam has hostile intentions
to everyone who is not a Muslim the
group that obtained the document says
it's shocking these meetings have been
taking place on the Parliamentary estate
the defense is that these are not
concerns about mainstream Islam this is
about political Islam and radical Islam
well you only have to look at the people
who are involved in this group this
isn't just about radical Islam or
islamist terrorism it is about Muslim
Islam per se it is about viewing Islam
as a supremacist religion baroness Cox
says the group's focus is on protecting
Muslim women from Sharia marriages that
are not legally registered and that she
has strong support from the Muslim
Community
but amid calls for greater transparency
here this all raises questions about who
is getting involved in the process of
democracy and how it's being paid for
Rob pal Sky News in Westminster